така Власне кажучи
практично фінал фінал буде в момент
передачі там на півфінал історії з
шилдами
історія важлива ми про неї говорили дуже
багато власне історія чий фінансовий бік
ще так досі і не закритий тому що там
розрахувалися з виробником взявши кредит
і приносимо віддати кредит в банку і це
надзвичайно важливо виключно змінити з
вашої допомоги це тільки можемо зробити
але те що ви бачите зараз те що ви
сьогодні ну по суті це насправді буде
перший прецедент в Україні коли люди які
донатили скидали гроші на
за допомогою армії зокрема на
бронетехніку вони зможуть сьогодні
прийти і отак от просто по- помацать
руками те що вони по суті і фінансували
і це стосується як шелдіви вони всі тут
стоять це стосується як цих дахів які
також частина лише тільки стоїть там
частина ще проводиться до ладу
ставляться підфарбовуються і так далі
тому надзвичайно важлива історія
Сьогодні ми познайомимо цю історію з
найбільшими донаторами ті які робили
внески більше п'яти тисяч ті які мають
відповідні футболки
котрими дарували на знак подяки і все і
сьогодні Ці машини по суті вирушають на
Схід і
будуть передані відповідного в
десантні війська і все далі це вже
питання військових вони можуть
використовувати їх за прямим
безпосередньо призначенням як зараз
прийнято казати там в рамках
контрнаступу але Будьмо тверезі в рамках
будь-яких військових дій які військові
будуть вважати обґрунтованими станом на
цей момент
А якщо ви знаєте що з ними можна робити
Ну слухайте що можна робити з
броне машиною яка має десантне
відділення Ну все що завгодно Це
доставка
особового складу на точку
будь-якого особового складу тому що ми
розуміємо що це може бути якщо там є б
там потреба там Окей евакуація якщо там
є потреба там довести кудись там бойову
групу
броньовик насправді є універсальний в
своєму класі тому Ну якщо з ними можна
робити питання треба ставити десантникам
вони чітко розуміють для чого їм
потрібно броньована десантна машина
Але ми всі бачили
музончик ну його треба завести можна і
зараз поставити насправді тому що
воно по Блютузу можна підключитися е-е і
насправді я так розумію що там для
настрою е-е
водієві і командирові відділення це буде
така панічна штука з якою ти піснею
[музика]
здох віднах всі але таку пісню поки нема
писали є пісня Ми вас всіх об'єм можна
так Ну але от
[музика]
це заложний мотить двіж і це ЗСУ Ну
насправді у нас е-е якщо там хто не
помітив то Ось ця
повномасштабна фаза цієї війни з лютого
і дотепер вже породила цілий музичний
напрямок
пристойних пісень різного жанру
з останнього що мене насправді так ну
позитивно вразило бо це такий
специфічний жанр але він вклався в
формат донесення змісту це бавовна це
блін весело це блін весело але це
змістовно цей про війну і і це правильно
що була в Криму правда ну я сподіваюсь
що це тільки початок але це не ми